All right, we have a special guest here intro-ing the show today, right, Craig? Yes, welcome to the show everybody. Wait, hang on a second, before you go, just welcome to SmartList and joyous, I don't know. Okay, so welcome to SmartList. Okay, that was good, but again, Craig, it doesn't seem like you're really welcoming me. Hey, how are your kids, Will? They're really good. When was the last time you saw them?
好的，今天我们有一位特别嘉宾来介绍节目，对吧，克雷格？是的，欢迎大家收听节目。等等，等一下，在你开始之前，先欢迎大家收听《SmartList》，还有……我不知道。好吧，欢迎收听《SmartList》。好的，这还不错，但再说一次，克雷格，你好像并没有真的在欢迎我。嘿，威尔，你的孩子们怎么样了？他们很好。你上次见到他们是什么时候？
What month are we? Wait, by the way, we're still Craig, we're still doing the intro, so just say welcome to SmartList. Hi, welcome to SmartList. Hi. There's everybody. Hi, Sean. Hi, guys. Sean.
现在是几月？等等，顺便说一下，克雷格，我们还在做开场白，所以只要说欢迎收听《SmartList》就行了。嗨，欢迎收听《SmartList》。嗨。大家好。嗨，肖恩。嗨，伙计们。肖恩。
How are you today? Sean is busy doing incredible work in Chicago per a very tough to please critic, apparently. Sean's got a very nice review. That's very nice. In the Chicago Tribune. We're all excited. That's very nice. And when do we get to see it?
你今天怎么样？肖恩在芝加哥忙着做一些不可思议的工作，据一位非常挑剔的评论家说，肖恩得到了一篇非常好的评论。那太好了。《芝加哥论坛报》上的。我们都很兴奋。那太好了。我们什么时候能看到它？
Do you want people coming out to Chicago to see it, or do you want us to wait till New York? It's entirely up to you. Here's the other thing, you don't even have to see it, because here's why. No, no, I want to. Because I'm not a huge fan of when other friends are like, you've got to see my movie. No, you're not that guy. You're not that guy. Yeah, so I really, truly don't.
你是希望人们去芝加哥看，还是希望我们等到纽约再看？这完全取决于你。还有一件事，你甚至不需要看，因为原因如下。不，不，我想看。因为我不太喜欢其他朋友说“你一定要看我的电影”。不，你不是那种人。你不是那种人。是的，所以我真的，真的不想。
Well, can I suggest this? Is there a world where when you're done and you come back home that we just do a dinner with our usual crew? And then, Sean, we have you kind of like a salon. We'll have you stand up and just do some choice monologues. Or you can do the whole thing. Or do the whole thing. That would be great. But just privately, so it's just us.
好吧，我可以建议一下吗？有没有可能等你忙完回来，我们和往常的伙伴们一起吃顿饭？然后，肖恩，我们把你像沙龙一样安排一下。让你站起来表演几段精选的独白。或者你可以表演整部剧。或者表演整部剧。那太棒了。但只是私下里，只有我们几个人。
I could do like a speed line through. Speed through would be great. And maybe just, I mean, not too much blocking, like a little bit so we get a sense of the space, obviously. And, Will, can I double back to your use of the word salon? Did you throw a salon in there? I sure did. What does that mean? Well, look it up.
我可以做一个快速的过场。快速过场会很棒。也许不需要太多的走位，只要一点点，让我们对空间有个概念就行。还有，威尔，我可以回到你刚才用的“沙龙”这个词吗？你刚才说了沙龙？我确实说了。那是什么意思？好吧，你自己查查。
I mean, I'm familiar with a salon wall. A salon wall is the wall with a bunch of pictures all put next to one another that form a larger singular square. Is that right? I think it is. Well, did you get a haircut? I did. Yeah. You got a body cut too and a fat face cut too.
我是说，我知道沙龙墙。沙龙墙就是那种把一堆画放在一起，形成一个更大的单一正方形的墙。是这样吗？我想是吧。好吧，你剪头发了吗？剪了。是的。你还修了身体毛，还修了胖脸。
You look great, man. What happened? Are you sick? Thank you. I love it when people say that. Thank you so much. You know, it's so crazy. So when I go to the theater, I have to have a COVID test every week, right?
你看上去很棒，伙计。怎么了？你生病了吗？谢谢。我喜欢人们这么说。非常感谢。你知道，这太疯狂了。当我去看戏的时候，我每周都得做一次新冠检测，对吧？
And so still, and so I missed this one day. So they said, oh, well, you have to just go to one of these like free clinic places. So I Google it. It says you can come in for, you know, just like walk in, you don't have to make an appointment. So I walk in and I'm not kidding you guys. There's nobody there. And the woman standing right when you walk in goes, do you have an appointment? No.
所以，我错过了这一天。他们说，哦，好吧，你得去这些免费诊所之一。所以我谷歌了一下。上面说你可以直接进去，你知道，不用预约。所以我走进去，我没骗你们。那里一个人都没有。那个站在门口的女人问，你有预约吗？没有。
And she goes, you have to make an appointment. I go, but it said walk in. She goes, yeah, but you still have to make one. So you can go back outside and scan the little digital thing on your phone. And I go, you're joking me right now. I go, you want me to walk outside? Yeah. So I walk out, I go, watch this.
她说，你必须预约。我说，但上面写着可以直接进去。她说，是的，但你仍然需要预约。所以你可以回到外面，扫描手机上的那个小数字码。我说，你现在是在跟我开玩笑吗？我说，你要我走出去？是的。所以我走出去，我说，看着。
And I looked at her through the glass, through the door. Never, never broke eye contact. No, this sounds like a real bait man. I was so angry. I took the big picture of the thing and I'm filling it out, just giving her evil looks. While I'm filling this out, I log in all my information. I walk in, she goes, can I help you? She wasn't even kidding.
我透过玻璃，透过门看着她。从来没有，从来没有移开过视线。不，这听起来像个真正的诱饵。我太生气了。我拍了那东西的大照片，一边填表，一边恶狠狠地瞪着她。在我填表的时候，我输入了所有的信息。我走进去，她说，有什么可以帮您的吗？她甚至不是在开玩笑。
She goes, do you have an appointment? Was it Edie McClerick? I go, wait, this is not happening. This is like a joke. So she goes, yeah, I have an appointment. She goes right over here to a line that doesn't exist. And then this guy at the front desk, he's like, do you have an appointment? I go, yes, I do.
她说，你有预约吗？那是伊迪·麦克莱克吗？我说，等等，这不可能。这简直是个笑话。所以她说，是的，我有预约。她指着这边一条根本不存在的队伍。然后前台那个家伙说，你有预约吗？我说，是的，我有。
He's like, great. And then he tells me to go, wait in this other line. There's no line. It's just a thing to go get tested. How good. And then you go outside and you look up at the, when you finally leave, you look up and you look back at the place and you look at the sign and it says Kafka COVID tests. Kafka.
他说，太好了。然后他让我去另一条队伍等。根本没有队伍。这只是一个去检测的地方。多好啊。然后你走出去，当你最终离开时，你抬头看，回头看那个地方，看那个招牌，上面写着“卡夫卡新冠检测”。卡夫卡。
Wow. How have you guys been? What's new? It's been a minute since we've all been hanging out. I know. I know. You guys were so kind to let us all take a couple of weeks off while I was in tech for Tracy.
哇。你们最近怎么样？有什么新鲜事吗？我们已经有一阵子没聚在一起了。我知道。我知道。你们太好了，让我能休几周假，当时我正在为《特蕾西》做技术排练。
Tech is when you light the whole play. Don't be short with, don't be testy with Tracy right then. Like you're exhausted to have to tell her. Is that what tech is? You're like, Tracy is. Technical. Anyway, so thank you guys. So that's what we haven't seen each other in a while.
技术排练就是给整部戏打光的时候。别对特蕾西不耐烦，别在那时候发脾气。就像你累得不得不告诉她一样。技术排练就是这个意思吗？你是说特蕾西是……技术性的。总之，谢谢你们。所以这就是我们有一阵子没见面的原因。
Sorry. I just want to go. This is a little off topic, but Jake, you've gone back to Pina's hair. What? Oh, I know. Remember when Jimmy said the top of your hair? Yeah. He did.
抱歉。我只是想说。这有点跑题了，但杰克，你又留回了皮纳的发型。什么？哦，我知道。还记得吉米说你头顶的头发吗？是的。他确实说了。
That did leave a mark. Yeah. So listener, what happens here? What are you doing? There's a direct part right in the middle. Well, it's a double cowlick. Okay. I'm not upstairs styling that and creating a double cowlick.
那确实留下了印记。是的。所以听众们，这里发生了什么？你在干什么？中间有一条笔直的缝。好吧，那是双发旋。好吧。我没在楼上做造型，也没弄出个双发旋来。
But yeah, it is for those familiar with the circumcised. It does look like a cowlick that twice. Yeah. There's a, well, I'm assuming what Jimmy meant when he said penis hair. Do you think he was talking about, because listener, we've got a double cowlick here, right? So we've got a cascade on one side and another one on the, like an M. They got it.
但确实，对于那些熟悉包皮的人来说，它看起来确实像个发旋，而且是两次。是的。有一个……好吧，我假设吉米说“阴茎毛”时是什么意思。你觉得他在说什么，因为听众们，我们这里有个双发旋，对吧？所以我们一边有一个瀑布，另一边有一个，就像个M字。他们懂了。
They got it. They got it. Okay. So what do you, what part of the penis do you think there's a lot of parts? Let me finish. There's something really crass here. Oh boy. What part of the penis, there's so many parts of the penis that could be this, I'm going
他们懂了。他们懂了。好吧。那你觉得阴茎的哪个部分，有很多部分？让我说完。这里有些非常粗俗的东西。哦，天哪。阴茎的哪个部分，阴茎有那么多部分可能是这个，我要
to say penis one more time. No, no. If they look at the art right now to the podcast and they're listening to, they can see what we're talking about. Right. Look, either way, you look like a dickhead. Here we go, guys. Listen, listen, we've got to get to it because I know it's so bad.
再说一遍阴茎。不，不。如果他们现在看播客的艺术图，他们正在听，他们能看到我们在说什么。对。看，不管怎样，你看起来像个混蛋。我们开始吧，伙计们。听着，听着，我们得进入正题，因为我知道这太糟糕了。
We, I tell you what's so good though is, is our guest today. Boy, they're not going to like this segue right off the. They're going to like, they're going to like it just fine. They're going to like it just fine because our guest is a very, very funny person and knows what it's like to be very funny all the time and likes to laugh. And that's because our, our friend, our guest today has participated in so many comedic films and TV shows. It's almost pointless to name them all.
我们，我告诉你什么很好，就是我们今天的嘉宾。天哪，他们不会喜欢这个转折的。他们会喜欢的，他们会喜欢的。他们会喜欢的，因为我们的嘉宾是一个非常、非常有趣的人，知道一直保持幽默是什么感觉，而且喜欢笑。那是因为我们的朋友，我们今天的嘉宾参与了太多的喜剧电影和电视节目。列举它们几乎毫无意义。
It's almost fun. But you, you see, Jason, you might know him. You might know him from the office. You might know him from what else? What you might know? Mr. Corral. Is it Mr. Corral? Hang on a second.
几乎很有趣。但是你，你看，杰森，你可能认识他。你可能从《办公室》里认识他。你可能从别的什么地方认识他？你可能认识什么？科雷尔先生。是科雷尔先生吗？等一下。
Hang on a second. I'm trying to, I'm trying to, I'm working my way there. So you might know him from the office. You might know him from Brooklyn Nine-Nine. You might know him from. I've got an apple express. You might know him from any one of these movies. You might know him from his new show, Killing It on Peacock and Sean, you just might know
等一下。我正在尝试，我正在努力。所以你可能从《办公室》里认识他。你可能从《神烦警探》里认识他。你可能从……我有《苹果快车》。你可能从这些电影中的任何一部认识他。你可能从他在Peacock的新剧《Killing It》里认识他，肖恩，你可能只是
him from college because it's none other than Craig Robinson. Oh my God. Sean. There he is. Oh, look at that. He's got a picture of himself. He's got a painting of himself behind him. Oh, listener.
从大学里认识他，因为他不是别人，正是克雷格·罗宾逊。天哪。肖恩。他就在那儿。哦，看那个。他有一张自己的照片。他身后有一幅自己的画。哦，听众们。
We have a two shot. Craig Robinson. Well, listen, first of all, how crazy is this to be on here with, with Sean? So walk us through this a little bit, Craig. I know Craig's so sick of me. Every time I see Craig, I tell him the same goddamn thing. He's like, yeah, Sean, when are you going to drop it? It's enough.
我们有一个双人镜头。克雷格·罗宾逊。好吧，听着，首先，和肖恩一起出现在这里有多疯狂？所以克雷格，带我们了解一下这个。我知道克雷格厌倦我了。每次我见到克雷格，我都告诉他同样该死的事情。他就像，是的，肖恩，你什么时候发布它？够了。
I see who doesn't know. Are there listening? Or me. Or these guys. So Craig, will you tell it if you want? We went to college together. We were both piano majors at Illinois State University. Well, let him tell it.
我看看谁不知道。他们在听吗？或者我。或者这些家伙。所以克雷格，如果你想说就说吧。我们一起上的大学。我们都是伊利诺伊州立大学的钢琴专业学生。好吧，让他说。
Now you're telling it again. We went to college together and we were both piano majors at Illinois State University. Sean and I. I mean, down till we were in the same classroom, Sean was making everybody laugh. But especially when we just be in the back just quiet, not supposed to talk. That was, that was the best. Yeah. Now Craig, are you as impressive as Sean is on the, on the keys?
现在你又在说了。我们一起上的大学，我们都是伊利诺伊州立大学的钢琴专业学生。肖恩和我。我的意思是，直到我们在同一个教室，肖恩都在逗大家笑。但特别是在我们安静地坐在后面，不应该说话的时候。那是，那是最好的。是的。现在克雷格，你在琴键上像肖恩一样令人印象深刻吗？
Oh, Craig's amazing pianist. A thousand percent less impressive. No, no. Sean is a super genius. You're incredible. But you were a major, like you don't just major in piano playing without being somewhat impressive. I mean, I do my thing. But now Sean will, Sean can sit down and play with the orchestra.
哦，克雷格是位了不起的钢琴家。百分之一千没那么令人印象深刻。不，不。肖恩是个超级天才。你很不可思议。但你是个专业学生，你不可能在不令人印象深刻的情况下主修钢琴。我的意思是，我做我的事。但现在肖恩会，肖恩可以坐下来和管弦乐队一起演奏。
I can sit down and play with the gospel choir. Yeah. There you go. That's better than I can do. That's better than I can do. That's very impressive. I'm more by ear. Do you remember that song you wrote?
我可以坐下来和福音合唱团一起演奏。是的。这就对了。那比我能做的要好。那比我能做的要好。那非常令人印象深刻。我更多是靠听力。你还记得你写的那首歌吗？
Someone's fucking my lady. Someone's fucking my lady. Fuckin' my girl. Remember that song? Did it doggy style? Of course. Wait, wait. Wait, is that, did you perform that with the, when you used to do the, you and Jerry Minor,
有人在操我的女人。有人在操我的女人。操我的女孩。记得那首歌吗？用狗爬式？当然。等等，等等。等等，那是，你是和……当你过去做那个的时候，你和杰瑞·迈纳，
you used to do that thing together? Yes, absolutely. And you would perform that and then it would be revealed that it was him who was fucking your lady? No, no, no. Jerry would be Jerry's Elle Witherspoon and Chucky. Yeah. I played Chucky and Jerry and Elle Witherspoon would be like, you know, I don't mean to be
你们过去一起做那个东西？是的，绝对。你会表演那个，然后会揭示是他在操你的女人？不，不，不。杰瑞会是杰瑞的艾尔·威瑟斯彭和查基。是的。我扮演查基，杰瑞和艾尔·威瑟斯彭会说，你知道，我不想显得
suspicious, but last night when my woman come home. So he's assuming somebody's fucking his lady. So he sings about it. And I'm like, somebody's fucking your lady. Somebody's fucking your girl. And then in the middle of the song, he's like, Chucky, I found, I found a piece of paper in my woman's pants pocket. I'm like, what is it saying?
多疑，但昨晚我女人回家的时候。所以他假设有人在操他的女人。所以他唱关于它的歌。而我就像，有人在操你的女人。有人在操你的女孩。然后在歌中间，他就像，查基，我发现，我在我女人的裤兜里发现了一张纸。我就像，上面写着什么？
It's a phone number. And I said, call it. And so he, he's like, it's ringing. So, you know, it's back and forth. And then the phone rings and I answer the phone. He's like, are you fucking my lady? Yes, I'm fucking yours. And, you know, Jerry explained this to me, Jerry Minor.
是一个电话号码。我说，打过去。所以他，他就像，正在响。所以，你知道，这是来回的。然后电话响了，我接了电话。他就像，你在操我的女人吗？是的，我在操你的。而且，你知道，杰瑞向我解释了这个，杰瑞·迈纳。
What's up, brother? He was like, he told me the concept. And, you know, it was, it was, I cracked up. I think it was based on the R. Kelly and R. Kelly would have Ron Isley in his videos is Mr. Big. So it's kind of based on that. It was such a genius. When Jerry told me a long, even long before that, he said, I'm going to make you famous.
怎么了，兄弟？他就像，他告诉了我这个概念。而且，你知道，它，它，我笑翻了。我想它是基于R. Kelly的，R. Kelly会在他的视频里让罗恩·艾斯利扮演大人物先生。所以它有点基于那个。这真是个天才。当杰瑞在那之前很久很久告诉我时，他说，我要让你出名。
Here's my Craig Robinson journey. Just, and then everybody here. So we met in college. We were music majors in college. Then we started dancing to Janet Jackson in the hallways. We would dance rhythm nation with each other. And then we, and we were. Those numbers are going to come out by the way.
这是我的克雷格·罗宾逊之旅。只是，然后这里的每个人。所以我们在大学认识。我们在大学是音乐专业的。然后我们开始在走廊里跳珍妮·杰克逊的舞。我们会一起跳《节奏国度》。然后我们，我们是。顺便说一下，那些数字会出来的。
We would, we would. Five, four, three, two, one. Who do you think led that charge? I'm going to give you one guess. And then, and then one of the funniest things. I was in a play called Love for Love by William Cos. Sure. No, no, sure, sure, sure.
我们会，我们会。五，四，三，二，一。你觉得是谁带头的？我给你一个猜测的机会。然后，然后最有趣的事情之一。我在威廉·科斯的戏《为爱而爱》里。当然，不，不，当然，当然，当然。
Yeah, yeah. It was a restoration comedy. And Craig was my understudy. So in the play, I had like one scene and I had to play the harpsichord. And as my understudy, he had to wear a powdered wig and like a whole regale. Like the 17th century. It was one of the funniest things I've ever seen. I can't remember that.
是的，是的。那是一部复辟喜剧。克雷格是我的替补。所以在戏里，我有一场戏，我必须弹大键琴。作为我的替补，他必须戴上粉末假发，穿得像个盛装。就像17世纪那样。那是我见过最有趣的事情之一。我不记得那个了。
I wrote a song and Craig sang it. Now, Sean is busy using a lot of this, a lot of this education and talent. Craig, when's the last time you really put your musical degree to work? Oh, two nights ago. Yeah, you're always playing out, aren't you? Yeah, I play, I play and sing in my comedy act. Yeah. You got very serious when you said that.
我写了一首歌，克雷格唱了它。现在，肖恩正忙着利用很多，很多这种教育和天赋。克雷格，你上次真正发挥你的音乐学位是什么时候？哦，两天前。是的，你总是在外面演奏，不是吗？是的，我在我的喜剧表演中演奏和演唱。是的。你说这话时变得非常严肃。
It's a serious act. Where is the act currently and can we go see it? I'll be at the Laugh Factory this evening. Here in Los Angeles? Here in Los Angeles. Oh, wow. At the late show. So, boom, you're on the list just like that.
这是一个严肃的表演。这个表演目前在哪里，我们可以去看看吗？我今晚会在笑工厂。就在洛杉矶？就在洛杉矶。哦，哇。在深夜场。所以，砰，你就在名单上了，就这样。
What time does that start? 9.30. Oh, Jason, he's two hours into the heavy, the heavy gummy. The second gummy, which is... You don't want me behind a wheel but 9.30. I'll tell you what, May 4 at the Troubadour, Craig Robinson and the Nasty Delicious, and you get to see my master's degree. I would love to see that.
几点开始？9点半。哦，杰森，他已经吃了两个小时的重型软糖了。第二个软糖，这是……你不想让我开车，但9点半。我告诉你，5月4日在游吟诗人，克雷格·罗宾逊和Nasty Delicious，你可以看到我的硕士学位。我很想看看那个。
And that's my birthday. Come on down. May the 4th be with you. What's nice? What's the Nasty Delicious? That's a multi-member band? Yes, there are nine of us. Let me see if I can...
那也是我的生日。来吧。愿5月4日与你同在。什么好？什么是Nasty Delicious？那是一个多成员乐队？是的，我们有九个人。让我看看我能不能……
Nine? Yeah, yeah. Because I got the horn section, including Reggie Hines, Winston. There's a horn? Yeah, and a Burt and LaKeisha Benjamin. These are all... And then my drummer's Aisa Watkins. Sure.
九个？是的，是的。因为我有管乐部分，包括雷吉·海恩斯，温斯顿。有管乐？是的，还有伯特和拉基莎·本杰明。这些都是……然后我的鼓手是艾萨·沃特金斯。当然。
Ben Gialances, my conga player. And then David Samson on guitar. And then my brother, Chris Robb, on Keys synthesizer. And several of us do voice... That's great. Your actual brother. My actual brother. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
本·吉亚兰斯，我的康加鼓手。然后大卫·桑姆森弹吉他。然后我兄弟，克里斯·罗布，弹键盘合成器。我们中有几个人做人声……那太棒了。你亲兄弟。我亲兄弟。是的，是的，是的。
Now, wait, Craig. I'm just going to back up for two seconds. I also remember, you called me at my mom's house in Glen Ellen, Illinois. you saw me in a McDonald's commercial and you were still a teacher, I think. And you're like, how did you do that? I'm like, what? You said, how do you get a commercial?
现在，等等，克雷格。我退后两秒钟。我还记得，你给我妈妈在伊利诺伊州格伦埃林的家打电话。你看到我拍了一个麦当劳广告，我想你当时还是个老师。你说，你是怎么做到的？我就像，什么？你说，你怎么接到广告的？
And I was like, what are you talking about? He's like, and I was like, you got to get your head shots. You got to make a resume. And we talked on the phone. I don't know if you remember that for a long time. I must have been, I don't know, 20, 19 years old, 20 years old, 21, something like that. Remember that?
我就像，你在说什么？他就像，我就像，你得去拍头像照。你得做一份简历。我们在电话里聊了很久。我不知道你是否还记得。我当时一定，我不知道，20岁，19岁，20岁，21岁，差不多那样。记得那个吗？
Do you remember that, Craig? No. No, Craig. I'm moving on. That's my favorite part of the story is that Craig doesn't remember it. Do you remember, Craig, do you remember teaching anybody? I used to teach.
你记得那个吗，克雷格？不。不，克雷格。我继续说。这是故事里我最喜欢的部分，克雷格不记得了。你记得吗，克雷格，你记得教过任何人吗？我过去教书。
I taught kindergarten through eighth grade. Come on. You're in Chicago and Indiana. What? Yeah, I wanted to get into that. So Craig, so hang on a second. So let's back up even further and we're gonna get into the teaching.
我教过幼儿园到八年级。得了吧。你在芝加哥和印第安纳。什么？是的，我想进入那个领域。所以克雷格，所以等一下。所以让我们退得更远一点，我们要进入教学领域。
Yeah. Your mom, was your mom a teacher or is a teacher? She was a teacher. She taught it when young, high school. She was my music teacher. She was your music teacher. So no wonder you and your brother are both musically inclined.
是的。你妈妈，你妈妈是老师还是老师？她是老师。她在年轻时教过，高中。她是我的音乐老师。她是你的音乐老师。所以难怪你和你兄弟都很有音乐天赋。
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. Our whole house was, you know, pianos, drums, horns, all kind of stuff was in it. It was like a music hall. That's wild. Okay, so your mom was a music teacher. So then you grew up with music all around. And did you guys all, did you jam out,
哦，是的，是的，是的。我们整个房子都是，你知道，钢琴、鼓、管乐，各种东西都在里面。就像个音乐厅。那太疯狂了。好吧，所以你妈妈是音乐老师。所以你从小就在音乐中长大。你们都，你们一起即兴演奏吗，
like everybody in the family? You and your brother? Jam out, shut up. Come on, man. I thought everybody at Christmas, like after every family in the world was like playing and singing, harmony, until one Christmas I was in LA and it was just quiet.
家里每个人？你和你兄弟？即兴演奏，闭嘴。得了吧，伙计。我以为全世界每个家庭在圣诞节，就像在演奏和唱歌，和声，直到有一个圣诞节我在洛杉矶，那里很安静。
I was like, and I wouldn't get the keyboard out the car and they were like, what? Christmas carols at Christmas. Sean, you keep threatening to play the piano at our Christmas gatherings. It hasn't happened yet. I know. It's not gonna happen.
我当时想，我不会把键盘从车里拿出来，他们就像，什么？圣诞节的圣诞颂歌。肖恩，你一直威胁要在我们的圣诞聚会上弹钢琴。还没发生呢。我知道。不会发生的。
Are you kidding? Yeah. Can we not make your deal or something like that? Is it a deal thing? Yeah, you guys have to make a deal with me. No, I, yeah, I was gonna pull out the, I was gonna get a piano at the last. This is what you're all at.
你在开玩笑吗？是的。我们不能达成什么协议之类的吗？这是个交易吗？是的，你们得和我达成协议。不，我，是的，我打算拿出，我打算在最后弄个钢琴。这就是你们都在做的。
Christmas carol. It kind of like stops a party. No, it doesn't. It doesn't. It's not the party. Remember one time at Jimmy's house, at Jimmy Barrow's house you got on the piano. Yeah.
圣诞颂歌。它有点像停止聚会。不，它不会。它不会。这不是聚会。记得有一次在吉米家，在吉米·巴罗家你上了钢琴。是的。
Which was fun. And Jason, remember that we were all like, oh, Jason, nobody tell Jason, don't invite Jason. I think Amanda was even there too, his wife. But he was like, don't mention it to Jason. But Will, it stops the party. People are like, oh, that's nice. And then everybody goes home when it's done.
那很有趣。杰森，记得我们都像，哦，杰森，没人告诉杰森，别邀请杰森。我想阿曼达当时也在，他妻子。但他就像，别跟杰森提。但威尔，它停止了聚会。人们就像，哦，那很好。然后当它结束时每个人都回家了。
When you stop playing piano, then everybody goes home. You're right. It's like when somebody goes, they watch this video and as soon as you pull the video out and show somebody, everything's over. I did that last night and that exact thing happened. Wait, what happened, Craig? I did that.
当你停止弹钢琴时，每个人都回家了。你是对的。就像当有人说，他们看这个视频，当你拿出视频给别人看时，一切都结束了。我昨晚做了那个，完全一样的事情发生了。等等，发生了什么，克雷格？我做了那个。
I put out a video and I started showing people because I'm so proud of this show, this one scene. And then the lights went off and everybody left home. And you did it on purpose or no? No, no. I did it not knowing if that's what happens when you show up with you. It's true.
我拿出一个视频，我开始给人们看，因为我为这个节目感到骄傲，这一场戏。然后灯灭了，每个人都回家了。你是故意的还是不？不，不。我做的时候不知道当你出现时会发生什么。这是真的。
It's a conversation, Ender. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. Craig, so your mom's a music teacher. You and your brother musically inclined. You were surrounded by your whole dump. So then you go to college and major in music with Sean Hayes. And Sean, you had already done Will and Grace
这是一个对话终结者。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目。克雷格，所以你妈妈是音乐老师。你和你兄弟有音乐天赋。你被你的整个垃圾包围了。所以你上大学，和肖恩·海耶斯主修音乐。肖恩，你当时已经拍了《威尔和格蕾丝》
by that point, right? I forget the timeline on that. No, McDonald's. He had been selling McRibs. He'd done McDonald's as a sitcom? I don't, listen, I'm not paying attention. Exclusive to the McRib campaign, I believe. I had already done one.
在那一点上，对吧？我忘了那个时间线。不，麦当劳。他一直在卖麦香肋排。他拍过麦当劳的情景喜剧？我不，听着，我没注意。我相信是麦香肋排活动的独家。我已经拍过一个了。
McRib, the sitcom. I wanna hear about like hungry, young, not knowing anything about the business, Craig. Yeah, exactly. So he calls Sean and, yeah. So that's what I'm getting to. Take your time. So you go to college and then what is that moment
麦香肋排，情景喜剧。我想听听关于饥饿、年轻、对生意一无所知的克雷格。是的，完全正确。所以他给肖恩打电话，是的。所以这就是我要说的。慢慢来。所以你上大学，然后那个时刻是什么
when you graduate college because then you become a music teacher? How did you make the leap from being a music major at Illinois State? That's a good question. It's a great question. To coming out to California and working as an actor. Well, I called Sean's mother's house. I remember that phone call.
当你大学毕业时，因为那时你成了音乐老师？你是怎么从伊利诺伊州立大学的音乐专业跨越过来的？这是个好问题。这是个伟大的问题。来到加利福尼亚并作为演员工作。好吧，我给肖恩妈妈家打了电话。我记得那个电话。
Okay, the leak. Yeah, but to that point, Craig, I had the same question that I can't believe I waited 30 years to ask you, which was what was that? What exactly it will just ask? Like, I remember that phone call. I'm not offended that you don't, but I was like, oh, that's so cool.
好的，泄露。是的，但说到这一点，克雷格，我有同样的问题，我不敢相信我等了30年才问你，那就是那是什么？威尔会问什么？就像，我记得那个电话。我不介意你不记得，但我当时想，哦，那太酷了。
Craig wants to get into acting, but what made you want to do that? I was chosen by comedy. Mm-hmm, yeah. Comedy chose me. Comedy chose you. I'm called a bitten by the bug, whatever you want, but I was in college.
克雷格想进入演艺圈，但是什么让你想做那个？我被喜剧选中了。嗯，是的。喜剧选中了我。喜剧选中了你。我被称为被虫子咬了，不管你怎么说，但我当时在大学。
I was like, I'm gonna do stand-up. I think my father, who was like serious attorney, serious corporate attorney, I think he inadvertently sparked it one day because he was like, because I was always so silly. And he's like, you know, people get paid to be silly like that. And I was like, excuse me, comedians. People get paid to do this stuff.
我当时想，我要做单口相声。我想我父亲，他是个严肃的律师，严肃的公司律师，我想他无意中有一天点燃了它，因为他就像，因为我总是那么傻。他就像，你知道，人们因为那样傻而得到报酬。我当时想，对不起，喜剧演员。人们因为做这些事情而得到报酬。
And that was one of the things that sat with me. Then in college, as I'm feeling this comedy, but comedians were like superheroes to me. Like you could see them, you just couldn't touch them, anything. But then I saw some people doing comedy in college. And that's what made me go, okay, I'm getting to this. Because there was people I could see and touch and knew.
那是让我深思的事情之一。然后在大学里，当我感受到这种喜剧时，但喜剧演员对我来说就像超级英雄。就像你能看到他们，你只是不能触摸他们，任何东西。但后来我在大学里看到一些人做喜剧。那就是让我去，好吧，我正在进入这个领域。因为有我能看到和触摸并认识的人。
And like, you have an act, how do you do that? So then once I graduated, I was full-on. Even by that point, I had driven to Chicago and back to go to like the Laugh, the Funding Firm, to see Richard Jenney speak just on a Saturday afternoon or something. But were you working on stand-up material at that point? At that point, in college, I had like a couple of jokes.
而且，你有表演，你是怎么做到的？所以一旦我毕业，我就全力以赴。即使在那一点上，我也开车去芝加哥又回来，去像笑，资金公司，去看理查德·詹尼在周六下午演讲之类的。但你当时在创作单口相声材料吗？在那一点上，在大学里，我有几个笑话。
I would go, Sean, do you remember this? The theater department would have these like Tuesday night, like almost like an open mic, but there was no mic. It was just somebody would come up and... It was called Theater of Ted. Theater of Ted. Ted's Theater. And people just performed with him.
我会去，肖恩，你记得这个吗？戏剧系会有这些像周二晚上的，几乎像开放麦，但没有麦克风。只是有人会上来……它叫泰德剧院。泰德剧院。泰德的剧院。人们只是和他一起表演。
And I got up to nerve and went up and kind of played the piano, messed around and told some jokes. And the first joke I think I ever wrote was a poem. Like, sometimes my father, you know, he comforts me. He'll say, stop crying. And I want to do this poem for you. Stop crying, stop crying right now before I give you something to cry about.
我鼓起勇气上去，弹了弹钢琴，胡闹了一下，讲了几个笑话。我想我写的第一个笑话是一首诗。就像，有时我父亲，你知道，他安慰我。他会说，别哭了。我想为你做这首诗。别哭了，别哭了，现在就别哭，在我给你点什么哭之前。
You're making a scene, you know, that's wrong. Just wait till we get home. And then, you know, you got a little reaction, whatever. And a couple of mothers in the start. So anyway, go to graduate and, you know, immediately I'm hitting the open mics and going to Second City. And, you know, things kind of progressed from there. And at some point, my buddy, Owen Smith,
你在制造场景，你知道，那是错的。等我们回家再说。然后，你知道，你得到了一点反应，不管怎样。还有几个母亲在开始。总之，去毕业，你知道，我立即在打开放麦，去第二城。而且，你知道，事情从那里开始进展。在某个时候，我的哥们，欧文·史密斯，
who's a big time Hollywood writer now, he goes, you could probably, you know, get on the sitcom or whatever. I forget what we talked about, but it was something about made me go, if I go into acting, I want to know what I'm doing. So I started, I went to Act One, I went to Second City, I went to Audition Center. Then I did, you know, get Def Comedy Jam from Def Comedy,
他现在是个大牌好莱坞编剧，他说，你可能，你知道，可以上情景喜剧之类的。我忘了我们聊了什么，但它让我去，如果我要进入演艺圈，我想知道我在做什么。所以我开始，我去了第一幕，我去了第二城，我去了试镜中心。然后我做了，你知道，从Def Comedy Jam得到Def Comedy，
what have you. That got me some eyes in Hollywood. I forced a manager to tell me I need to move to Hollywood. Like, you think I should move here, right? You think I should? You think I should? And I ended up winning this contest. I won a few contests, but I did, got a development deal. I went to Montreal and got a development deal.
等等。那让我在好莱坞得到了一些关注。我强迫一个经理告诉我我需要搬到好莱坞。就像，你觉得我应该搬到这里，对吧？你觉得我应该？你觉得我应该？我最终赢得了这个比赛。我赢了几场比赛，但我确实，得到了一个开发协议。我去了蒙特利尔并得到了一个开发协议。
You went to Just for Laughs? I went to Just for Laughs. Yeah, and then I did, it was New Faces. Came back and went on 14 meetings, and I'm getting a development deal from one of them. And that's what eventually got me to move to Los Angeles. Did Sean say anything on that first phone call that was helpful at all?
你去Just for Laughs了？我去了Just for Laughs。是的，然后我做了，那是新面孔。回来并参加了14次会议，我从其中一个得到了开发协议。那就是最终让我搬到洛杉矶的原因。肖恩在那个第一个电话里说了什么有帮助的话吗？
I'm sure he did. Sean was always very positive, very helpful. Probably. So Craig, but I'm trying to go along the time, because we're all the same age, roughly. Jason's the oldest here, obviously. 72. But you, Sean and I are about the same age.
我肯定他说了。肖恩总是非常积极，非常有帮助。可能。所以克雷格，但我正试图顺着时间走，因为我们年纪都差不多。杰森显然是这里最老的。72。但你，肖恩和我年纪差不多。
We're all, I'm 51. Sean's 51. Are you 51 as well? I'll be 51 in October. Okay. So we're all in the same ballpark. And I, you know, whatever, 50 and young play, obviously skew a younger and have lots and a big presence on social media. So obviously in touch with young people too.
我们都是，我51岁。肖恩51岁。你也51岁吗？我十月就51岁了。好吧。所以我们都在同一个范围内。而且我，你知道，不管怎样，50岁和年轻表演，显然偏向年轻，在社交媒体上有很大的存在感。所以显然也和年轻人有联系。
And if you just reach out and look for my handles and subscribe here, but the point is this. The point is this. Subscribe. There are a few. Subscribe. Nothing made me sound older than that. The point is, the point is, what are those gap?
如果你只是伸出手寻找我的把手并在这里订阅，但重点是这个。重点是这个。订阅。有几个。订阅。没有什么比这让我听起来更老了。重点是，重点是，那些差距是什么？
How long were you teaching before you? Cause you're doing all this stuff in college. You realize like, okay, I want to be a standup. Your dad tells you, by the way, my dad was also a lawyer for many years, a corporate lawyer. And they were always like, what are you doing? Not like, hey, you're silly people that make money. They're like, stop goofing around and get serious.
你在教书多久之前？因为你在大学里做所有这些事情。你意识到，好吧，我想成为一名单口相声演员。你父亲告诉你，顺便说一下，我父亲也是一名律师多年，公司律师。他们总是说，你在做什么？不是像，嘿，你们是赚钱的傻瓜。他们就像，别胡闹了，认真点。
But what are you doing from that moment? You graduate college, you've got it in your mind. You want to do comedy. You start teaching though instead for a while. Like, but while you're teaching her, do you have a foot out the door? Exactly the whole time, I think. I remember the first year I started teaching,
但从那一刻起你在做什么？你大学毕业，你心里有数。你想做喜剧。但你却教了一段时间书。就像，但在你教书的时候，你有一只脚在门外吗？我想整个时间都是。我记得我开始教书的第一年，
the teachers are like, watch Mr. Holland's opus. Don't get stuck here. So, I taught one year in Indiana and Franklin Elementary and then also Eggers Elementary. And so one was like, and Whiting, and then one was in this other part of Indiana. But it was a good 45-minute drive in between. And it was sweet because two days a week,
老师们就像，看《霍兰先生的乐章》。别被困在这里。所以，我在印第安纳教了一年，富兰克林小学，还有埃格斯小学。所以一个是像，和怀廷，然后一个是印第安纳的另一个地方。但中间有45分钟的车程。而且很甜，因为一周两天，
I had like a two-hour break to drive in between schools. And one was like a white school, one was like a black school. It was amazing. So I taught there for a year. Then I got into a program called Teachers for Chicago where you get paid to teach and they get you your masters. So I was getting my, I got my masters to teach for Chicago and then you're supposed to be there for a few years,
我有两个小时的休息时间在学校之间开车。一个是像白人学校，一个是像黑人学校。这太棒了。所以我教了一年。然后我进入了一个叫“芝加哥教师”的项目，在那里你得到报酬教书，他们让你拿到硕士学位。所以我正在拿到我的，我拿到了我的硕士学位去教芝加哥，然后你应该在那里待几年，
committed to Chicago. That's amazing. And your masters was in music? Yes, music education. That's so cool. Talk to me, was teaching these kids, these young kids, was it lovely on the whole or frustrating? I always marvel at the patience that teachers
致力于芝加哥。那太棒了。你的硕士学位是音乐吗？是的，音乐教育。那太酷了。告诉我，教这些孩子，这些年轻的孩子，整体上是可爱的还是令人沮丧的？我总是惊叹于老师的耐心
of young, young, young children have. You know, obviously I love kids, but you spend seven hours with kids, with kids trying to teach them X, Y, and Z, trying to figure out how to manage their attention and their focus. When the hand goes up, the mouth goes shut, that kind of thing. Yeah. How'd you do with that?
对非常、非常、非常小的孩子。你知道，显然我爱孩子，但你花七个小时和孩子在一起，试图教他们X、Y和Z，试图弄清楚如何管理他们的注意力和专注力。当手举起来时，嘴就闭上，那种事情。是的。你做得怎么样？
Did you have like this teacher, my younger started, like they did this little, like there's like, there's like, there's clap signals to like you go quiet when you hear that. Like did you have, how did you, how did you manage with all that? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I would say like, hey y'all shut the fuck up! Yeah, that's efficient.
你有没有像这个老师，我年轻时开始的，就像他们做了这个小的，就像有拍手信号让你安静下来当你听到那个时。就像你有，你是怎么，你是怎么管理所有这些的？是的，是的，是的，是的。我会说，嘿，你们都闭嘴！是的，那很有效。
No clap. It's clear. That's very clear. The, for the most part, the kids were cool, you know. Then there were a few classes. One class was like this special ed class, this behavior kind of thing, where they had a security guard trying to teach you now all day until they came to music.
没有拍手。很清楚。那非常清楚。大部分情况下，孩子们很酷，你知道。然后有几个班。一个班就像这个特殊教育班，这种行为之类的东西，他们有一个保安试图整天教你，直到他们来上音乐课。
So then, what the hell might have to like play the dozens and do your mama jokes, and you didn't even jump in and be like, so anyway, Beethoven, you know. Right. You had to kind of hide it a little bit. That was that. But then, you know, if you were interested enough, they would sit and pay attention. And then, if you weren't.
所以然后，该死可能不得不像玩几十个并做你妈妈的笑话，你甚至没有跳进去并像，所以总之，贝多芬，你知道。对。你不得不稍微隐藏它。那就是那样。但然后，你知道，如果你足够感兴趣，他们会坐下来注意。然后，如果你不。
Were there kids, did you were able to identify kids who were like really talented and go like hey? Yeah, for sure. And could you identify the kids that were the problems too? Well, I mean, there were kids who just needed a little bit more than others. Yeah, I needed you. I was a problem. I needed you. You know, I wouldn't have got kicked out so much.
有没有孩子，你能够识别出非常有天赋的孩子并像嘿？是的，当然。你也能识别出有问题的孩子吗？好吧，我的意思是，有些孩子只是比别人需要更多一点。是的，我需要你。我是个问题。我需要你。你知道，我不会被踢出去那么多次。
But you turned out great. You turned out okay. There were probably kids that were like, that you probably didn't connect with like your personality level too, but you had to, right? You're like, this kid coming in now, I can't stand this kid. And then you have to act like you can't, right?
但你结果很好。你结果还可以。可能有些孩子，你可能没有在个性水平上与他们联系，但你必须，对吧？你就像，这个孩子现在进来，我受不了这个孩子。然后你必须表现得好像你不能，对吧？
Not that I can't stand it. It was just like they couldn't stand me. You know, it just didn't. You and the authoritative position, it wasn't, you know, it just didn't sit well. What's the worst punishment you ever gave to a kid? First punishment? I don't send them back to their teacher.
不是我受不了。只是他们受不了我。你知道，它只是没有。你和权威位置，它不是，你知道，它只是不合适。你给孩子最坏的惩罚是什么？第一次惩罚？我不把他们送回老师那里。
Yeah, that's it. I had them 40 minutes a week. Were you trying any or material out on these youngsters? Funny question. I did. Once I started learning, you know, really, I mean, you know, getting into comedy, I was, you know, obviously going to the open mics
是的，就是这样。我一周有他们40分钟。你在这些年轻人身上尝试过任何材料吗？有趣的问题。我试过。一旦我开始学习，你知道，真的，我的意思是，你知道，进入喜剧，我，你知道，显然去开放麦
weekly, nightly. And yeah, I would practice my stagemanship. It wasn't necessarily the jokes. Right. You know what I mean? Yeah, you've got a locked in audience. They have to be there. Yeah.
每周，每晚。而且是的，我会练习我的舞台技巧。不一定是笑话。对。你知道我的意思吗？是的，你有一个锁定的观众。他们必须在那里。是的。
They're not locked in or they do have to be there. You learned how to deal with hecklers too. A little bit. Yeah. A little shitty little eight year olds running their mouths. Jesus, man. Hey, dad of the year, cool it. By the way, Maple gave me a great joke the other day.
他们没有被锁定，或者他们确实必须在那里。你也学会了如何处理起哄者。一点点。是的。一些糟糕的小八岁孩子在跑他们的嘴。天哪，伙计。嘿，年度最佳父亲，冷静点。顺便说一下，枫树前几天给了我一个很棒的笑话。
She said, this is my 10 year old. She said, how do you make holy water? I said, how? She goes, you boil the hell out of it. That's good, actually. You can use that one tonight, Craig. That's free. That's good.
她说，这是我10岁的孩子。她说，你怎么做圣水？我说，怎么做？她说，你把地狱煮出来。那其实很好。你今晚可以用那个，克雷格。那是免费的。那很好。
Tell her, ask her, what kind of car did Jesus drive? What would she say? A Chrysler. It's good. It's terrible. We'll be right back after these messages. You're welcome. Hang on a second.
告诉她，问她，耶稣开什么车？她会说什么？克莱斯勒。那很好。那很糟糕。我们会在这些信息后回来。不客气。等一下。
So, Craig, how did the office come about? Because that was... What a question. You were so... Thank you. You were so... I loved you on the office, by the way. And I told you, I always think you're a hilarious dude.
所以，克雷格，办公室是怎么来的？因为那是……什么问题。你太……谢谢。你太……我喜欢你在办公室，顺便说一下。我告诉过你，我一直认为你是个搞笑的家伙。
Thank you, bro. But I loved you on the office. Tell me, how did that... What was that? Before that, too, I remember driving on the CBS Radford lot. And you were the car behind me or in front of me or something. And I was like, Craig? And you just moved to LA.
谢谢，兄弟。但我喜欢你在办公室。告诉我，那是怎么……那是什么？在那之前，我也记得开车在CBS雷德福地段。你是在我后面或前面的车之类的。我当时想，克雷格？你刚搬到洛杉矶。
I was like, this is what? You're in LA now? That's so cool. And then you said you were going on audition and audition. And then you just popped up on the office. It was just so awesome. And you know what you told me? You were like, tell me about all the auditions you went on
我当时想，这是什么？你现在在洛杉矶？那太酷了。然后你说你要去试镜和试镜。然后你就在办公室里冒出来了。那真是太棒了。你知道你告诉我什么吗？你就像，告诉我你参加的所有试镜
and how you wanted to be sitting in the corner with a razor blade, you know? Because it's just denial, denial, denial. You guys get so close. So yeah, I've thought about that actually a lot. Well, that sounds like great advice, Sean, that you did, Craig. No, he'd know how you would be getting denied. And he'd be like, that's how you feel. Like you just want to...
以及你是怎么想坐在角落里拿着剃须刀片的，你知道吗？因为那只是否认，否认，否认。你们靠得太近了。所以是的，我确实想过很多。好吧，那听起来像伟大的建议，肖恩，你做的，克雷格。不，他会知道你是怎么被拒绝的。他会像，那就是你的感觉。就像你只是想……
Yeah. I'm going to... Right. That's the worst. Craig, welcome to LA. You're going to spend most of your time in the corner with a razor blade. Good luck. Oh, thanks, Sean.
是的。我要……对。那是最好的。克雷格，欢迎来到洛杉矶。你将大部分时间花在角落里拿着剃须刀片。祝你好运。哦，谢谢，肖恩。
Thanks, old friend. Let me know how it goes. How much do you want to grab a bite? Wait, so the office is what, 2004 or five, something like that? Yes. Let me see. Yeah. Yeah, 2005, I think.
谢谢，老朋友。让我知道进展如何。你有多想吃点东西？等等，所以办公室是什么，2004或5年，差不多那样？是的。让我看看。是的。是的，2005年，我想。
There goes Mary Lou Arnett. I know. I'm good with dates. So was it just like a standard audition process on that or anything colorful about that process of landing that sweet gig? So I went in and a full circle, Greg Daniels and I don't know, 13 other people sitting there, Greg, front and center. And he goes, I saw your video.
玛丽·卢·阿内特在那儿。我知道。我擅长日期。所以那是一个标准的试镜过程还是关于那个 landing 那个甜蜜演出的过程有什么丰富多彩的吗？所以我进去了，一个完整的圆圈，格雷格·丹尼尔斯和我不知道，其他13个人坐在那里，格雷格，正面和中心。他说，我看了你的视频。
Just talking about somebody's fucking my lady. Oh, wow. And he's like, not getting any funnier than that, which probably should be a border confidence, a shot up for me. But for me, I'm like, oh, fuck. Yeah. Well, if I get any funnier than this, obviously, it's not going to be funny. Yeah.
只是在谈论某人正在和我女士鬼混。哦，哇。他说，没有比这更好笑的了，这对我来说可能应该是一个边界信心，一个打击。但对我来说，我心想，哦，该死。是的。好吧，如果我再好笑一点，显然，这就不好笑了。是的。
You should have shaken the script pages and said, yeah, not with this shit, you know, and then just walked out. Walked out. That would have killed. Jesus. And, you know, they had us do one of the little models, the sides to the camera. Well, they call it confessionals and do that paragraph. And deadpan is like, I'm a huge fan.
你应该摇晃剧本页面说，是的，不是这种垃圾，你知道，然后直接走出去。走出去。那会很棒的。天哪。而且，你知道，他们让我们做了一个小模型，对着镜头。好吧，他们称之为忏悔室，做那一段。而面无表情就像，我是个超级粉丝。
Yeah. That's your thing. You know, like Harvey Corvin and Leslie. What was Leslie Nassman from Police Squad? Leslie Nassman. Yeah. Those are my cats, man. So I went in there just like, so the office I thought was tailor made for my style.
是的。那是你的风格。你知道，就像哈维·科文和莱斯利。那个《警察小队》里的莱斯利·纳斯曼是谁？莱斯利·纳斯曼。是的。那些是我的猫，伙计。所以我进去的时候就像，所以我认为办公室是为我的风格量身定做的。
Yeah. So you do that. You do that audition. You do, you do that talking head and you do the deadpan thing for Greg and the 13 people in the room. You walk out and you think, what nailed it? I want to be on the office or you let it go and just like on with my day. Oh, you got to let it go.
是的。所以你做了。你做了那个试镜。你做了，你做了那个谈话头，你为格雷格和房间里的13个人做了那个面无表情的事情。你走出去，你心想，搞定了吗？我想在办公室工作，还是你放手，就像继续我的一天。哦，你必须放手。
Move on. I didn't know it was another audition. Yeah. I would throw my script away or my sides away like this. Like that'll show them. You know, like I'm not going to think about that at all. And all you do is think about it. Yeah.
继续前进。我不知道那是另一次试镜。是的。我会像这样扔掉我的剧本或我的侧面。就像那样会给他们看。你知道，就像我根本不会去想那个。而你所做的只是去想它。是的。
I would always, I'd love to say as I was leaving, good luck with this. Like in other words, like I'm going to not give myself this part before you not give this to me. I did it after every audition. So bad. Oh God. The arrogance is so gross. Well, but it was also sort of like, you know, feigned humility.
我总是，我离开时喜欢说，祝你好运。就像换句话说，就像在你没给我这个角色之前，我不会给自己这个角色。我在每次试镜后都这样做。太糟糕了。哦，天哪。这种傲慢太恶心了。好吧，但这也有点像，你知道，假装谦虚。
Like, well, you know, I'm not assuming I'm going to get this. And the probability that I do not please good luck with this. Not a lot of people know this. Jason also invented pray hands. Yeah. Yeah. I started that. Yeah.
就像，好吧，你知道，我并没有假设我会得到这个。而我不得到的概率，祝你好运。没多少人知道这一点。杰森还发明了祈祷手。是的。是的。我开始了那个。是的。
Small bow, tiny hands. Oh, pray hand. The worst is when you put the audition out of your mind and then, you know, two months later, your mom's like, Hey, so what happened with the spider man? Did you get that? Right. My mom's favorite thing to always do is always just to sort of just let me know what A-list directors I should be working with.
小鞠躬，小手。哦，祈祷手。最糟糕的是当你把试镜抛在脑后，然后，你知道，两个月后，你妈妈说，嘿，那么蜘蛛侠发生了什么？你得到了吗？对。我妈妈最喜欢做的事情总是只是让我知道我应该和哪些一线导演合作。
Oh, you know what? You know what? You should do a film with Steven Spielberg. Like, oh, is that it? Okay. Oh, hang on. Let me write this down. My father would be like, you look like David Allen Gray.
哦，你知道吗？你知道吗？你应该和史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格拍一部电影。就像，哦，是那样吗？好吧。哦，等等。让我写下来。我父亲会说，你看起来像大卫·艾伦·格雷。
You should do something with him. Call him. Call him up. Just call him up. All right. So Craig, so what, how's your music passion nowadays? Are you, is it still? What's a bigger passion for you?
你应该和他一起做点什么。给他打电话。给他打电话。直接给他打电话。好吧，那么克雷格，那么你现在的音乐热情如何？你是，它还在吗？对你来说什么是更大的热情？
The acting or the music? The music. It's always the music. Still the music? Music is the first love. So what are you listening to mostly right now? What, what, at least what genre of music? Some Chris Rob.
表演还是音乐？音乐。永远是音乐。还是音乐？音乐是初恋。那么你现在主要在听什么？什么，至少是什么类型的音乐？一些克里斯·罗布。
Chris Rob. It's my brother. That's his brother. Yeah. That's my brother. Yeah. And some Craig Rob. We've been working on something that I don't know if it ever come out because I'm the
克里斯·罗布。是我兄弟。那是他兄弟。是的。那是我兄弟。是的。还有一些克雷格·罗布。我们一直在做一些我不知道是否会发布的东西，因为我是
most into it, but we have several songs about ready to go. What's it sound like mostly? What type is it? Hard rock. The first one is like a kind of a smooth R&B. Smooth. All I want to do is love you, babe. Sure.
最投入的，但我们有几首歌准备好了。听起来主要是什么样的？是什么类型的？硬摇滚。第一首有点像平滑的R&B。平滑。我只想爱你，宝贝。当然。
So is it safe to say then that you act to pay the bills for your music passion and like follow that? Oh, Sean. Sometimes. Uh-huh. Like I'll do a bunch of comedy shows. And if I know the band is going to do a show at House of the Blues and only get, you know, 10 grand, I might do a bunch of shows around there to make sure, you know what I'm saying?
那么可以肯定地说，你表演是为了支付你的音乐热情的账单，并追随它吗？哦，肖恩。有时。嗯哼。就像我会做一堆喜剧表演。如果我知道乐队要在蓝调之家做一场演出，只得到，你知道，1万块，我可能会在那附近做一堆演出，以确保，你知道我在说什么吗？
House of the Blues still going? House of the Blues still up and around? Yes. Is that a close? Is it? Yeah. You know, I take that back. We send my answer.
蓝调之家还在营业吗？蓝调之家还在吗？是的。那是一个关闭吗？是吗？是的。你知道，我收回那句话。我们发送我的答案。
I don't know. Okay. You don't know. We'll strike it. We'll strike that. We'll strike it. I'm sorry. You're committed already.
我不知道。好吧。你不知道。我们会划掉它。我们会划掉它。我们会划掉它。对不起。你已经承诺了。
And now back to the show. Craig, is there a dream project where you want to combine like music and like a dream film of yours or a dream role? Or musical theater? Sean? Six, seven, eight. Anything? But can you think of anything that Craig could just fall right into?
现在回到节目。克雷格，有没有一个梦想项目，你想结合音乐和你梦想中的电影或梦想角色？还是音乐剧？肖恩？六，七，八。什么都可以？但你能想到克雷格可以直接投入的任何事情吗？
Like a beautiful glove? Yeah, a million things. A million things. How about promises, promises? I saw that on Broadway. Did you see it? Yeah. It was very sweet of you to come.
就像一只漂亮的手套？是的，一百万件事。一百万件事。《承诺，承诺》怎么样？我在百老汇看过那个。你看了吗？是的。你来真是太好了。
I remember that. It was amazing. You were amazing. Thank you, thank you. He was amazing. Would you like to do a run on Broadway? Oh, I would love it. Yeah, absolutely.
我记得那个。太棒了。你太棒了。谢谢，谢谢。他太棒了。你想在百老汇演出吗？哦，我很乐意。是的，绝对。
Really? What about you? Sean, what could you and Craig do together? That would be a great two-hander. Stir crazy, the musical. Yeah. Wait a minute. Wait what?
真的吗？你呢？肖恩，你和克雷格能一起做什么？那会是一个很棒的双人戏。音乐剧《疯狂的搅拌》。是的。等等。等等什么？
Wait, Craig, that's a really good idea. That's a great idea. Well, who's someone's going to steal that right now? You guys have how many weeks before we air this episode to write it? No, they can't steal it. They can't steal it. They can't steal it. He's already got it.
等等，克雷格，那是个非常好的主意。那是个好主意。好吧，谁现在要偷走那个？你们在我们播出这一集之前有几周时间来写它？不，他们不能偷走它。他们不能偷走它。他们不能偷走它。他已经有了。
That's a good idea, Craig. Who holds the rights for that? Craig owns it and now Sean works for Craig. Hey, listen. This is a great idea. I'm here where witnesses, Craig's dad's a lawyer. We're going to get the papers drawn up. That was fast.
那是个好主意，克雷格。谁拥有那个的版权？克雷格拥有它，现在肖恩为克雷格工作。嘿，听着。这是个好主意。我在这里作为证人，克雷格的爸爸是律师。我们要把文件起草好。那很快。
That was very fast. Do you like that idea of going to Broadway and doing eight shows a week and all the rehearsals and all that stuff? I had a taste of it a few years back with Chris Rock. We were doing a pearly and it wasn't even the musicals. And it was Chris Rock and I wish I could remember everybody's name. Kimberly and Bear. And then some real heavy hit of Broadway people.
那非常快。你喜欢去百老汇，每周演八场，还有所有的排练和所有那些东西的想法吗？几年前我和克里斯·罗克尝过一次。我们当时在做《珀利》，甚至不是音乐剧。那是克里斯·罗克，我真希望我能记住每个人的名字。金伯利和贝尔。还有一些真正的百老汇大腕。
And then Bo, what's Bo's brother? Bo Bridges. Bo Bridges, yeah. Bo Bridges was in it too. So they flew us to New York. To my dad too. And we were there for like a whole week just rehearsing the shit out of this play. And then the first day, this big producer comes in.
还有博，博的兄弟是谁？博·布里奇斯。博·布里奇斯，是的。博·布里奇斯也在里面。所以他们把我们飞到纽约。也飞到我爸爸那里。我们在那里待了整整一周，只是疯狂地排练这部戏。然后第一天，这个大制片人进来了。
He also does music. Can't think of his name. Big time director was working with us throughout the week. And the last day he came in. So, you know, first let's see where it was from the beginning to the end. So I wouldn't mind. I didn't mind. I know it wasn't a, you know, rigorous.
他也做音乐。想不起他的名字。大牌导演在整个星期里都在和我们一起工作。最后一天他进来了。所以，你知道，首先让我们看看它从头到尾是什么样子。所以我不会介意。我不介意。我知道它不是一个，你知道，严格的。
But they did, they did. Ultimately they did not end up doing the play. Is that the deal? Yeah, we are. I don't know what happened. I think it was because of COVID. You know what I think it is. And this is, I'm just guessing, you know what I think it happened?
但他们确实，他们确实。最终他们没有演这部戏。是这样吗？是的，我们是。我不知道发生了什么。我想是因为新冠。你知道我认为是什么。而且这是，我只是在猜测，你知道我认为发生了什么吗？
I think that maybe because you couldn't remember anybody's name. Maybe if you remember some of them. It came to me with all the names I thought of. It's too late. No, they moved on. Rick Rubin. Is that a? Rick Rubin, sure.
我想也许是因为你记不住任何人的名字。也许如果你记得他们中的一些人。它带着我想到的所有名字来到我这里。太晚了。不，他们继续前进了。里克·鲁宾。是一个吗？里克·鲁宾，当然。
It's a pretty big name. He was a part of it and it did not go forward. Is Rick Rubin in the music? And I think Scott Rudin was producing it. Sam Mendes, I think it was direction, but they did not go forward. The biggest names and Craig's like, I'm sorry, one more time with your name. So you have not yet tested your stamina in a Broadway run yet. Is that correct?
这是一个相当大的名字。他是其中的一部分，但它没有继续进行。里克·鲁宾在音乐界吗？我想斯科特·鲁丁在制作它。萨姆·门德斯，我想是导演，但他们没有继续进行。最大的名字，而克雷格就像，对不起，再说一次你的名字。所以你还没有在百老汇演出中测试过你的耐力，对吗？
I have not. I have done 14 shows a week doing comedy though. Whoa. There you go. That's something. Two shows a night. That's a lot. Sean is just coming off.
我没有。不过我做过每周14场喜剧表演。哇。这就对了。那是一回事。一晚两场。那很多。肖恩刚刚结束。
Sean's starting. He's embarking on it. He heard us yammering on earlier. He just got unbelievable reviews there at the Goodman in Chicago. He's unbelievable and he's being very modest about it. And I ended up tweeting out his review because I'm just so proud of him. Congratulations. Thank you.
肖恩开始了。他正在着手做这件事。他听到了我们早些时候的唠叨。他在芝加哥的古德曼剧院获得了令人难以置信的评论。他令人难以置信，而且他对此非常谦虚。我最终发推文发布了他的评论，因为我为他感到骄傲。恭喜。谢谢。
What are you in? It's a new show called Good Night Oscar. Hold for applause. Still holding. And still holding. So this is about the movie industry completely going away. And it only being television, right? And just, and therefore just the Emmy, the Emmy awards.
你在演什么？这是一个叫《晚安奥斯卡》的新剧。等待掌声。还在等待。还在等待。所以这是关于电影业完全消失。而只有电视，对吧？因此只有艾美奖，艾美奖。
Oh, I see. Good night, Oscar. There we go. Oh, no. Jason, good for you. Oh, thanks. That's fun. No, that's a fun joke, Jason. We need stuff to cut.
哦，我明白了。晚安，奥斯卡。这就对了。哦，不。杰森，为你高兴。哦，谢谢。那很有趣。不，那是个有趣的笑话，杰森。我们需要剪掉一些东西。
So Craig, you mentioned Greg Daniels. So you work with Greg on the office and also with Mike Sure on the office. Sure. Our old friend. And then Mike goes on Duke Parks and Rec Brooklyn, nine, nine, which you do with Mike and Dan Gore who created it. And then you have tremendous success on Brooklyn nine, nine. And then you and Dan Gore start a new show together.
所以克雷格，你提到了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。所以你在《办公室》和格雷格一起工作，也在《办公室》和迈克·舒尔一起工作。当然。我们的老朋友。然后迈克继续做《公园与游憩》、《神烦警探》，你和迈克以及共同创作它的丹·戈尔一起做。然后你在《神烦警探》中取得了巨大的成功。然后你和丹·戈尔一起开始了一个新节目。
That's coming out soon on Pika. Yeah. It might already be out. Right. Yes. Yes. Called killing it. Killing it.
很快就要在Pika上播出了。是的。可能已经播出了。对。是的。叫《杀手》。杀手。
It. So you've reunited with the great Dan Gore, whom I also know from, from Parks and Rec, who's a absolutely hilarious guy. Great. And how do you, how did killing it come about? This is about the singing hit man. Yes. Guys.
它。所以你和伟大的丹·戈尔重聚了，我也从《公园与游憩》中认识他，他是一个绝对搞笑的家伙。太棒了。你是怎么，杀手是怎么来的？这是关于唱歌的杀手吗？是的。伙计们。
That's what I thought. They just, they come so fast and I just got to share them with you. And anyway, continue. That's what they say. That's what the ladies say. No. Craig, please cut him off. I had a meeting with Dan.
我就是这么想的。它们来得太快了，我必须和你们分享。总之，继续。他们就是这么说的。女士们就是这么说的。不。克雷格，请打断他。我和丹开过会。
He was like, dude, you know, we love working with you. You're the best part about a lot of the things that you're in. Let's, let's figure something out. So Mark Shulman, my manager. Happy birthday, Mark. It's his birthday today. Hey, Mark. But, um, uh, and then, uh, Luke Del Tradici.
他就像，伙计，你知道，我们喜欢和你一起工作。你是你参与的很多事情中最好的部分。让我们，让我们想出点什么。所以马克·舒尔曼，我的经理。生日快乐，马克。今天是他的生日。嘿，马克。但是，嗯，呃，然后，呃，卢克·德尔·特拉迪奇。
That's it. Right. We, uh, we all got together, you know, and then they kept pitching, they were pitching these ideas and like, well, which, you know, and it was a musical ideas or this idea of this. And then there was this, this really interesting thing about snake killing in Florida where people were killing snakes for money because they're overrun because back in the day drug dealers were buying them to be,
就是这样。对吧。我们，呃，我们都聚在一起，你知道，然后他们一直在推销，他们在推销这些想法，就像，好吧，哪个，你知道，它是音乐想法还是这个想法。然后有一个非常有趣的事情，关于佛罗里达州的杀蛇，人们因为钱而杀蛇，因为它们泛滥成灾，因为过去毒贩买它们是为了，
you know, like Scarface will have you, but then they sent them out and nothing eats the snakes. They eat everything. So, um, they need them. That's the show. You're a snake killer. That's the show. Come on.
你知道，就像《疤面煞星》会有的，但后来他们把它们放了出去，没有什么吃蛇。它们吃掉一切。所以，嗯，他们需要它们。这就是节目。你是个杀蛇人。这就是节目。来吧。
Hang on a second. The cock is putting up a snake killer hit man. The cock. This is, this is, yeah, do it for the cock. By the way, Jason, this is actually not a terrible idea of rebranding for Peacock to go simply as the cock. The cock. Or maybe that's coming next on the cock.
等一下。公鸡正在放一个杀蛇杀手。公鸡。这是，这是，是的，为了公鸡做吧。顺便说一句，杰森，这实际上不是一个糟糕的品牌重塑主意，让Peacock简单地称为公鸡。公鸡。或者也许那是接下来在公鸡上。
Oh. No. Coming out. No, wait, we got it. Hang on. We're all around it. Let's just hold on a second here. We are really close.
哦。不。出来。不，等等，我们得到了。等等。我们都在它周围。让我们在这里等一下。我们真的很接近。
Streaming, streaming from the cock. Yeah. Right. I think we got it. There we have it. Okay. So continuing. So you're literally a snake killer.
流媒体，从公鸡流媒体。是的。对吧。我想我们得到了。我们就在那里。好吧。所以继续。所以你真的是个杀蛇人。
Come on. Kill snakes. Yeah. Craig, that's the pitch. I start. You have the world listening right now. I'm giving you one more shot. Literally kill his snakes.
来吧。杀蛇。是的。克雷格，这就是推销。我开始。你现在有全世界在听。我再给你一次机会。字面上杀掉他的蛇。
Yeah. Okay. I'd watch it. I'd watch it. Wait, what time can we find this on? Streaming on the cock. It's streaming on the cock. It's streaming on the cock.
是的。好吧。我会看的。我会看的。等等，我们可以在什么时间找到这个？在公鸡上流媒体。它在公鸡上流媒体。它在公鸡上流媒体。
Okay. Okay. We got a lot of interesting things coming from the cock this season. I'm sorry. On the cock stream. So, so you're okay. But listen, come on.
好吧。好吧。我们这个赛季从公鸡那里得到了很多有趣的东西。对不起。在公鸡流媒体上。所以，所以你没问题。但是听着，来吧。
Listen. Wait, I want to talk about like, what about ladies in your life? Like, are you dating anybody, anybody special in, in the Craig Robinson? I'm single. I'm single. I'm single. I'm single.
听着。等等，我想谈谈，你生活中的女士们怎么样？比如，你在和任何人约会吗，克雷格·罗宾逊生活中的任何特别的人？我单身。我单身。我单身。我单身。
I'm single. I'm single. I'm single in your seinway come as vault. I'm single. As you cant see, I'm on the bar. Speaking of Robinson. I'm single af. Okay.
我单身。我单身。我单身。我单身。我单身。正如你所见，我在酒吧。说到罗宾逊。我单身。好吧。
You're single af? Should we be on the lookout for you? No, no, no, I'm happily single. Okay. Got it. What does that mean? When you say you're happy single, does that mean you've got it all worked out?
你单身吗？我们应该留意你吗？不，不，不，我快乐地单身。好吧。明白了。那是什么意思？当你说是快乐单身时，那意味着你已经把一切都搞定了吗？
You've got you're swiping on certain nights, you're going out to certain clubs on other nights, certain bars on the nights and you've got a great routine going. What's behind that? No distractions. I'm just enjoying. I'm very, very busy and it's all good because like in the past last year or so, like, people wouldn't get mad at me and just be like, break up.
你在某些晚上刷卡，在其他晚上去某些俱乐部，在某些晚上去某些酒吧，你有一个很棒的例行公事。那背后是什么？没有干扰。我只是在享受。我非常，非常忙，而且一切都很好，因为就像过去一年左右，就像，人们不会对我生气，只是像，分手。
That's a whole other podcast, but they've been, you know, removing themselves from my life. It's brought me a piece that I'm like, oh, this is, this is nice and then so maybe I got to figure out. Did you maybe instead maybe think about why you're upsetting these women and therefore be able to continue dating women? Bro, that says there's a whole other podcast. Don't put it on Craig.
那是另一个播客，但他们一直在，你知道，把自己从我的生活中移除。它带给我一种平静，我心想，哦，这，这很好，然后也许我得弄清楚。你也许反而考虑过为什么你让这些女性心烦意乱，从而能够继续和女性约会吗？兄弟，那说那是另一个播客。别把它放在克雷格身上。
Okay. Here, how about that? I'll tell you this. One girl hit me shoes like. It's gotta be Craig's fault. Why, why, why have you never put me in anything but gave me a job? This is one of the, this is the question. Uh-oh.
好吧。这里，那个怎么样？我告诉你这个。一个女孩打我，她说。一定是克雷格的错。为什么，为什么，为什么你从来没让我参与任何事情，但给了我一份工作？这是其中之一，这是问题所在。哦哦。
Wow. Well, what, you know, and I said, well, you don't sing or do comedy or play music. You know, she texted back. I'm playing music right now. Oh, she was just listening to music. I'm playing music right now. So something she was like, I'm, you know, I'm fine with not, not speaking with him. Okay.
哇。好吧，什么，你知道，我说，好吧，你不会唱歌或做喜剧或演奏音乐。你知道，她回短信说。我正在播放音乐。哦，她只是在听音乐。我正在播放音乐。所以有些事情她就像，我，你知道，我不介意不，不和他说话。好吧。
But then take this other girl who I just met in New York, who has wrote me a whole show and like, like came to see my show and I'm like, well, here's somebody I can use on the squad. This girl's amazing. Sure. And then what happened? Oh, no, we stayed in touch. Oh.
但后来带上我在纽约刚认识的另一个女孩，她为我写了整场演出，就像，就像来看我的演出，我心想，好吧，这是我可以在小队中利用的人。这个女孩太棒了。当然。然后发生了什么？哦，不，我们保持联系。哦。
But not romantically. Oh, not romantically. Not romantically. Not romantically. So you got her on nice romantically, but. Look, I put like, I got my eye on somebody, but I'm not, you know. Okay. Okay.
但不是浪漫地。哦，不是浪漫地。不是浪漫地。不是浪漫地。所以你让她浪漫地，但是。看，我放了像，我盯着某人，但我没有，你知道。好吧。好吧。
That's fair enough. That's fair enough. We're not going to push you. It's fun. It's fun to have a crush. Did your mom and dad give you any pressure? Like, come on, Craig. I'm going to go over you about settling down.
那很公平。那很公平。我们不会逼你。这很有趣。有暗恋对象很有趣。你妈妈和爸爸给你压力了吗？比如，来吧，克雷格。我要因为安定下来而找你麻烦。
No. No. Living my life. You're living your life. You're happy. Now, is my life like, was that ever pissed off that you weren't going into corporate law and that you were going into comedy and music instead? Y'all absolutely not pissed that I went into corporate law, but he saw this as pie in the
不。不。过我的生活。你在过你的生活。你很开心。现在，我的人生就像，那是曾经因为你没有进入公司法而感到生气，而是进入了喜剧和音乐吗？你们绝对没有因为我进入公司法而生气，但他把这看作是天上的馅饼。
sky. Yeah. And I think his quote was, you're going to lose that good job. Right. And now, now you've proven them wrong. And now, does he give it up? Does he say, uh, I was, I was wrong. You were right.
是的。我想他的话是，你会失去那份好工作。对。现在，现在你证明他们错了。现在，他放弃了吗？他说，呃，我，我是错的。你是对的。
Good for you. I don't think he'll ever say that. There's always, there's always something he's, you know, twisting the needle. Right. Right. They don't know you. The parents, they know how to do that, don't they? Like the white people know.
为你高兴。我不认为他会那样说。总是有，总是有什么东西他在，你知道，扭动针。对。对。他们不了解你。父母，他们知道怎么做，不是吗？就像白人知道一样。
They don't, the black people don't know you that well. And then people don't really want your autographing in you. People don't want an autograph. People don't, it's always something to keep going. Right. Right. Well, it keeps you hungry, right? The only approval.
黑人不太了解你。然后人们真的不想让你签名。人们不想签名。人们不想，总是有什么东西要继续。对。对。好吧，它让你保持饥饿，对吧？唯一的认可。
But I think that that's, that's a parenting style. I think you're right. It's just like, if they give it up, then they think that you're going to get lazy or something or you know what I mean? So they're like, they're like, in their mind, it's like even, even subconsciously they're like, I'm motivating him. And I feel like I'm doing the opposite. I don't know, it's wrong.
但我认为那是，那是育儿风格。我想你是对的。这就像，如果他们放弃了，那么他们认为你会变懒或者什么，或者你知道我的意思吗？所以他们就像，他们就像，在他们的脑海里，就像甚至，甚至潜意识里他们就像，我在激励他。我觉得我在做相反的事情。我不知道，这是错的。
I'm making a mistake. I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm the, I'm the problem, like the whole participation award thing. I think I'm complimenting my kids too quickly for what is at some, some, sometimes just mediocrity. Right. In, in a, in a, in a, in an unkind view of things, but I'm, I'm trying to say, well, that was great. We keep doing, keep doing more.
我犯了一个错误。我，我，我，我，我是，我是问题所在，就像整个参与奖的事情。我想我太快地称赞我的孩子了，因为有时，有时只是平庸。对。在，在，在，在一种不友善的观点中，但我，我试图说，好吧，那太棒了。我们继续做，继续做更多。
But am I, am I, am I conditioning them for an unrealistic world where they're going to get applauded for just doing the norm? I think it's a balance, like everything. I think it's a balance. You got to praise them and you got to teach them. Right. Craig, when you were teaching these kids, would you, would you give them, would you give them a pat on the back for a C or would you wait for at least a B?
但我，但我，我是在为一个不现实的世界训练他们，在那里他们会因为做正常的事情而受到鼓掌吗？我认为这是一种平衡，就像一切一样。我认为这是一种平衡。你必须称赞他们，你必须教导他们。对。克雷格，当你教这些孩子时，你会，你会给他们一个C的拍拍背，还是你会至少等一个B？
Oh, you got to, no, Sean hit it on the head and Jeff got to praise them and you got to teach them. I can tell you my, my niece and nephew, you know, they're, they want to be in the business and my niece was, was like, here I have an idea. It's a dope, dope idea and then she told me idea and it was like, there was no, there was zero development, something like that. And it was, you know, you have to show something and say, I'm writing and then you got to explain to them, hey, when you take these scripts in, you're competing against people who go
哦，你必须，不，肖恩说到了点子上，杰夫必须称赞他们，你必须教导他们。我可以告诉你我的，我的侄女和侄子，你知道，他们想进入这个行业，我的侄女就像，这里我有一个主意。这是一个很棒，很棒的主意，然后她告诉我主意，就像，没有，零发展，类似的东西。而且它是，你知道，你必须展示一些东西并说，我在写，然后你必须向他们解释，嘿，当你拿着这些剧本进去时，你在和那些去学校学习剧本的人竞争，这个那个和其他。所以它，它很难，因为我知道有些东西听起来很刺耳，但我确实让他们知道或者他们大多数人知道，嘿，你可以做到。它，它不像你想象的那么容易。你对这个行业的生意感兴趣吗，克雷格？还是你更像是一个放手的人，蛋糕做好了就给我打电话。你有截止日期应用程序吗？正是。
to school for scripts and this and that and other. So it's, it's hard to, cause I know some stuff comes off harsh, but I do let them know that or most of them know that, hey, you can do this. It's, it's not as easy as you think it is. Are you more, are you like into the business of the business at all, Craig? Or are you more like a hands-off, call me when that's the cake is made. Do you have the deadline app? Exactly.
正是。我喜欢，我喜欢做好的蛋糕。我，我的手在一些事情上，但我把它们举起来，就像我的乐队之类的，但我，在很大程度上，我不，但表演的事情和，在，在整个好莱坞的事情，你只是像，如果有东西进来就给我打电话。正是。所以你就像一个寻求发展并把项目放在一起并写它的人。有几件事，但是的，我没有，不够。
Exactly. I like the, I like the made cake. I have, my hands are in some things, but I put them up, like my band and stuff like that, but I, for the most part, I don't, but the acting thing in the, in the, in the whole Hollywood thing, you're just like, just call me if something comes in. Exactly. So you're like one to seek out development and put projects together and write that. There's been a couple of things, but yeah, I'm not, not enough.
这就像有人说，嘿，你打鼓。看，我可以保持节奏，对吧？对。但我不是鼓手。是的。你知道我的意思吗？所以是的，我，我，我的手有几件事，在很大程度上，事情会来，好吧，让我们，你知道，让我们看看那个。
It's like somebody say, hey, you play the drums. Look, I can keep a beat, right? Right. But I'm not a drummer. Yeah. You know what I mean? So yeah, I've, I've, I've had my hand a couple of things for the most part, things will come and okay, let's, you know, let's see that through.
是的。那是一个，你知道，对不起，只是为了，只是为了打断一下。杰森，今天早上交易中有任何有趣的进展吗？好吧，听着，每个人都在真正监控，你知道，华纳兄弟和Discovery Plus的合并。但没有，没有，没有大的希尔默脚踝，今天早上有什么项目吗？不，我的意思是，你知道，听着，迪士尼仍然在，你知道，不要说同性恋的事情上有麻烦，每个人都在关注那个。
Yeah. That's a, you know, I'm sorry, just to, just to interrupt for one second. Jason, any interesting developments in any of the trades this morning? Well, listen, everyone is really monitoring the, you know, the merger there at the Warner Brothers and Discovery Plus. But no, no, no big, no big Hilmer's ankle, any projects this morning? No, I mean, you know, listen, Disney still having trouble with the, you know, don't say gay thing and everyone's keeping their eye on that.
他们这里有一个撤退，所以有一个问题，你得到警报。你肯定会得到警报。哦，当然。好吧，等等。这是一个日期，它叫什么？截止日期。截止日期应用程序。我有一个贝特曼应用程序。
They got a retreat coming up here and so there's a problem with the, you get alerts. You definitely get alerts. Oh sure. Well, hang on. This is a date, what is it called? Deadline. Deadline app. I have a Bateman app.
是的。它真的给了我截止日期的亮点。任何时候，任何时候我在交易中有任何东西，第一个祝贺我的人是杰森。那是很久以前的事了，威尔。记得你以前在我有发布时称赞我吗？是的。以前有很多支持。好吧，我不读交易了。
Yeah. It just really gives me the highlights of the deadline. Anytime, anytime I have anything in the trades, the first person to congratulate me is Jason. That was a long time ago, Will. Remember when you used to compliment me when I had releases? Yeah. It used to be a lot of support. Well, I don't read the trades anymore.
我应该读。我可能应该读。我也不读。所以，所以今晚的节目是音乐和笑话的结合。是的。是的。我真的很想来看。所以5月4日。
I should. I probably should. I don't either. So, so tonight's show is a combination of music and of jokes. Yes. Yes. I really want to come see it. So May 4th.
我会，我会看到的。5月4日在Troubadour。是的。5月4日在Troubadour。那不难记住。不，那很好。我很高兴Troubadour又开始行动了，因为它感觉好像在那里关闭了一会儿。
I will, I will see that. May 4th at the Troubadour. Yeah. May 4th at the Troubadour. That's not hard to remember. No, that's good. I'm so happy the Troubadour is back in action because it feels like it was closed there for a minute.
没有确认？杰森？是的。有人想展示吗？不确定，但我认为有一段时间有一种病毒在传播。我们开放了。它关闭了。不，我，让我检查一下截止日期。
No confirmation? Jason? Yeah. Anyone want to show it? Not sure, but I think there was a virus that was going around for a little while. We're open. It's closed. No, I'll, let me check the deadline.
所以杀手，克雷格·罗宾逊要出来了。它将在公鸡上可用，在公鸡上流媒体，伙计，我很兴奋看到它。我喜欢你做的一切。你是个如此搞笑的家伙。而且最重要的是，而且它不是，你不能总是对每个人都这样说。你是个超级好人。每次我见到你，你都是那种当你看到时，你会像，我很高兴见到克雷格·罗宾逊。
So killing it, Craig Robinson is coming out. It's going to be available on the cock, streaming on the cock, man, I'm excited to see it. I love everything you do. You're such a hilarious dude. And on top of it all, and it's not, you can't always say this about everybody. You're a super nice guy. And every time I see you, you're one of those guys that when you see, you're like, I'm so happy to see Craig Robinson.
是的，当然。你有一种很好的氛围。嗯哼。同样的问题。是的。很棒的氛围，伙计。我们祝你一切顺利。我们占用了你太多的时间。
Yeah, for sure. You got a good vibe. Mm-hmm. It's the same problem. Yeah. Great vibe, dude. We wish you all the best. We've taken up way too much of your time.
谢谢你加入我们，伙计。是的，谢谢你在这里，克雷格。见到你总是很有趣。荣幸是我的，哟。感激。谢谢。谢谢，克雷格。谢谢，伙计们。
Thanks for joining us, man. Yeah, thanks for being here, Craig. It's always so fun to see you. Pleasure was mine, yo. Appreciate it. Thank you. Thank you, Craig. Thank you, pals.
再见，伙计。再见。克雷格·罗宾逊。克雷格·罗宾逊。克雷格。超级有趣。我得去看看。你一直说克雷格。
Bye, buddy. Bye. Craig Robinson. Craig Robinson. Craig. Super fun. I got to see it. You keep saying Craig.
不，我说了。克雷格。克雷格·罗宾逊。你说克雷格了吗？好吧。我的意思是，我的G是C邻居，当然。顺便说一句，这让我想起了，我想我之前在这个东西上讲过的一个愚蠢的笑话。我肯定会再讲一遍。
No, I did. Craig. Craig Robinson. Did you say Craig? Okay. I mean, my G is C adjacent, for sure. By the way, that reminds me of, I think a dumb joke I told before on this thing. I'm going to definitely tell it again.
我的新公司，我们正在做，霉菌很大，所以它叫邻近减排，你在哪里。那真的很紧。哦，是的。只是和枫树分享那个。是的，所以我得去看杀蛇秀。是的。我想知道他们每周如何塑造30分钟的娱乐节目。
My new company, we're working on, Mold is big, so it's called Adjacent Abatement, that where you are. That's really tight. Oh, yeah. Just share that one with Maple. Yeah, so I got to see the SnakeKilling show. Yeah. I want to know how they're shaping 30 minutes of entertainment weekly on that.
我想看看那个。那是一个挑战。如果有人能做到，那就是克雷格，因为他太，他是那些人之一，我喜欢他在办公室里的角色达里尔，因为他太搞笑了。他太面无表情了。他往往感觉像是唯一一个他和我们的伙伴，克拉斯在那里扮演吉姆。他们是唯一两个不完全疯狂的人，当然还有扮演帕姆的珍娜。
I want to see that. That's a challenge. If anybody could do it, it's Craig because he's so, he was one of those, I loved his character Daryl on the office because he was so funny. He was so straight face. He kind of oftentimes felt like the only one who he and our buddy, Kras playing Jim over there. They were the only two who weren't completely insane and Jenna obviously who played Pam.
现在刚命名了三个角色。他似乎总是那个，他真的很享受，我喜欢他和迈克尔·斯科特之间的动态，因为达里尔会怂恿他，你知道，卡雷尔的角色去做愚蠢的事情。不是吗，但你不觉得吗，我知道，我对此说得太多了。我们在大学里有完全相同的专业，我们都遵循完全相同的道路。那不奇怪吗？是因为作为古典钢琴家没有钱赚吗？
Now just named three characters. And he seemed to be the guy who was always like, and he really enjoyed, I love the dynamic between him and Michael Scott because Daryl kind of would egg him on, you know, Carell's character to do stupid things. Isn't that, but don't you think it's, I know, I've gone on too much about it. We both have the exact same major in college and we both follow the exact same path. Isn't that weird? Is it because there's no money to be made as a classical pianist?
好吧，有那个，但我年轻时并没有真正考虑过那个。好吧，太棒了，杰森。你刚刚激怒了地球上的八个人。我在开玩笑。有八个人。当然，那里有大钱可赚。是的，不，但他在大学里让我笑得太厉害了，我们总是会出去玩，让对方笑。
Well, there's that, but I didn't really think about that before when I was young. Well, great, Jason. You just enraged eight people on the planet. I'm joking. There are eight people. Of course, there's great money to be made there. Yeah, no, but he made me laugh so hard in college and we would always hang out and make each other laugh.
看到他的旅程真是太疯狂了。你们在一起走过这段旅程这么久真是太有趣了，就像杰森和你进进出出对方的生活，现在你们老了回头看，你们都，不，没有，但这只是，你们两个都非常成功，这有点罕见。是的，这很罕见。我们过去常走在走廊里，唱着和谐，我们过去常唱着《不仅仅是言语》的和谐。
It's just so wild to see his journey. It's funny that you guys have been on this journey for so long kind of together like a Jason and you come in and out of each other's lives and now that you're older to look back and you both, no, there's no, but it's just been, you guys have both been really successful and that's kind of rare. Yeah, it is rare. We used to walk down the halls and sing the harmony to, we used to sing the harmony to more than words.
你记得那首歌吗？我通常，我不擅长那种歌，像流行歌曲。我通常更擅长摇篮曲。那做得很好。聪明，丢失，聪明，丢失。SmartList是100%有机的，由贝内特·巴巴科、迈克尔·格兰特·特里和罗布·阿姆朱尔夫手工制作。聪明，丢失。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Do you remember that song? I'm usually, I'm not great with those kinds of songs like pop songs. I'm usually better with lullaby. That was well done. Smart, lost, smart, lost. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjurf. Smart, lost. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你还记得那首歌吗？我通常不太擅长那种流行歌曲。我更擅长唱摇篮曲。那首歌唱得真好。Smart, lost, smart, lost。SmartList 是由 Bennett Barbaco、Michael Grant Terry 和 Rob Amjurf 100% 有机且手工制作的。Smart, lost。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。